la expresión polinomio al 36 y cúbica
menos cien y puede factorizar se como 4
y por m
por m menos g donde mg son enteros
fátima escribió que g podría ser igual a
3 ernesto escribió que g podría ser
igual a 10 cuál de los estudiantes está
en lo correcto muy bien entonces cuando
vemos esta expresión que tenemos aquí
arriba podría parecernos no sé quizás
aterradora por tantas letras pero en
realidad sólo tenemos que ver que an
factor izado un 4 y por ejemplo desde
acá verdad de esta expresión así que una
vez que hemos factor izado 4 y podemos
ver que quizás lo que nos queda es algo
así como como una diferencia de
cuadrados verdad que de hecho puede
factorizar se de esta forma así que como
siempre te invito a que hagas una pausa
y trates de resolver este problema cuál
sería el valor correcto para él para la
letra g digamos muy bien entonces por
supuesto la idea es factorizar 4 ley
luego factorizar tanto como puedas
muy bien ahora vamos a hacerlo todos
juntos nosotros vamos a fijarnos en la
expresión 36 de kubica menos 100 muy
bien entonces tenemos 36 de kubica menos
muy bien y la idea es primero factorizar
4 y muy bien entonces vamos a factorizar
4 y tenemos este primer término vamos a
factorizar 4 y y nos preguntamos por
quién tenemos que multiplicar a 4 y para
que nos dé 36 de kubica y podemos
simplemente hacer la división verdad 36
entre 4 nos da 9 y que kubica entre y
nos da que cuadrada muy bien y podemos
verificarlo 4 por 9 son 36 y porque
cuadradas es de kubica
muy bien entonces esto corresponde a
nuestro primer sumando que tenemos acá
muy bien ahora restamos y tenemos que
factorizar 4 de verdad entonces nos
preguntamos qué número o qué expresión
tenemos que multiplicar a 4 y para
obtener 100 y eso otra vez podemos
hacerlo dividiendo verdad 100 entre 4
nos da 25
25 y he dividido entre llenos de uno muy
bien entonces podemos otra vez
confirmarlo 4 por 25 son 100 por 1 es de
ahora para que todo esto quede más claro
déjenme déjenme hacer esto vamos a
enmarcar a qué corresponde cada término
este primer término corresponde a esta
expresión que tenemos aquí mientras que
este segundo término corresponde a esta
segunda que tenemos de este lado muy
bien entonces de aquí es mucho más claro
que podemos factorizar cuatro y verdad
podemos factorizar cuatro y de aquí
cuatro y de acá y entonces tenemos la
siguiente expresión
4 que multiplica a otra expresión verdad
de hecho esa expresión simplemente será
9 y cuadrada verdad tendremos 9 de
cuadrada y luego restamos 25
25 y esto es algo muy agradable para
digamos para este problema porque
queremos justamente ver que esto es una
diferencia de cuadrados verdad sí quizás
es la primera vez que observas algo como
una diferencia de cuadrados te
recomiendo ver los vídeos que tenemos de
este tema en khan academy verdad pero
bueno esta expresión la podemos
reescribir de la siguiente de la
siguiente forma esto será 4 y que
multiplica aún a una expresión verdad
que de hecho es 3 y elevado al cuadrado
verdad simplemente 3 y elevado al
cuadrado serán 3 al cuadrado que es 9 y
al cuadrado será de cuadrada y luego
restamos un número elevado al cuadrado
en este caso será 5 al cuadrado 5 al
cuadrado es 25 entonces podemos ver que
esto es una diferencia de cuadrados y lo
que sabemos de la diferencia de
cuadrados es lo siguiente si tenemos
algo de la forma cuadrada
nos ve cuadrada esto lo podemos
factorizar de la siguiente forma es un
producto verdad de dos expresiones en
este caso el primero será a + b
y el segundo de ellos será a menos
- ve muy bien en este caso particular
que tenemos abajo nuestra corresponde a
3 y nuestra be corresponde a 5
así que si x si escribimos esta
expresión ahora factor izando esto como
como un producto de dos binomios
entonces tendremos cuatro y que
multiplica a nuestro primer binomio y
luego al segundo y el primero de ellos
será 3 y 5
3 y 5 y el segundo de ellos será 3 menos
53 y menos 5 muy bien y ahora ya podemos
revisarlo en términos del problema
original queríamos ver si fátima o
ernesto escribieron bien esta expresión
tomando g igual a 3 og igual a 10
entonces podemos ver que por supuesto
aquí se encuentra el 4 y aquí tenemos 4
y verdad por otro lado tenemos esta
expresión m y tenemos m ya que aquí
sería 3 de verdad entonces aquí estamos
diciendo que la m vale 3 y finalmente
tenemos la expresión g y menos que
verdad que aquí corresponde a cinco y
menos cinco entonces podemos decir que
ge es igual a cinco y si vemos la
respuesta de fátima y la respuesta de
ernesto fátima dijo que podría ser igual
a tres y ernesto dijo que podría ser
igual a diez así que en realidad ninguno
de ellos estaba en lo correcto verdad la
respuesta correcta es tomando
igual a 5 así que cuál de los
estudiantes está en lo correcto
podemos decir que ninguno así que este
este ejercicio fue interesante porque en
realidad es un poco truculento